are we always
that's the sound of 348 Ugandan MPS
celebrating
they've just overwhelmingly passed a new
law
only one person voted against it
and the law that these MPS are cheering
for
it's one that makes it illegal for
lesbian gay bisexual trans ugandans to
have a relationship with someone of same
sex
we only have our morals we'll protect
our children and we are making this law
we are making this law for ourselves we
are making this law for our children who
are making this love for the children of
our children that's Musa aquarium one of
those MPS this country will stand firm
we are going to
[Music]
uganda's anti-homosexuality act adds
life in prison even the death penalty as
a punishment further criminalizing the
LGBT plus community
thank you we have always been
discriminated we have always been
tortured we have always been denied
access to different services so we are
not safe at all and I'm scared what's it
like to be LGBT Plus in a country where
the state wants to send you to prison
for who you are and why has Uganda set
itself upon this path
I'm Kamali Melbourne and this is the Sky
News Daily
[Music]
Human Rights Watch will join me on the
podcast later but first j malucha a
transgender man is the director of the
LGBT plus Rights group fem Alliance
Uganda
of course right now I am not theft and
we are not safe as LGBT persons in
Uganda because now the bill is now a low
I expected that this law was going to
pass because there was a lot of pressure
from the general public the
parliamentarians the government
officials is in French African countries
who are supporting it so we expected
that it was going to pass
Jay what's it like being LGBT Plus in
Uganda being an LGBT person in Uganda is
train me no criminalized so it's not a
good thing but it's not a good
environment that we are living in as
LGBT people in Uganda because we have
always been discriminated we have always
been tortured we have always been denied
access to different services and needs
we have been thrown out of schools we
have been denied Access to Health
Service provision we have been sent away
from homes our families have denied us
sent away from our jobs
and actually we can't get jobs Because
of Who We Are so it's not something good
to be LGBT
so we are not safe at all and I'm scared
and uh fear that most of the LGBT people
are trying to escape and leave a country
the situation is too bad scary
uh there is a lot of anxiety it's not
good
many in the community are looking to
leave the country would you if you could
at the moment
um
I'm not uh ready to leave because I'm a
leader in my community and most of the
people look up to me I really don't want
to run away and leave them behind I I
feel like I should stay and fight this
battle with my people because
in my heart I feel it's not right to run
away if we all keep on running away and
then who will stand for our rights who
will fight these battles who will be
there because it's not only us we have
the Young Generation coming up will they
also have to run away all the time this
is our country this is where we are born
we have rights as other human beings we
are not different from any human being
how's it been with your family since you
started Living your truth I mean has it
been for you and your family and those
that were close to you
uh of course as a trans man
uh when I was growing up I didn't know
that uh I was this when I was eight
years I realized I wanted to do a lot of
boyish things and the good thing with
that I was a sports person I I play
basketball
so I would come a flight through Sports
because I knew if my family got to know
about it
they would
throw me out
because it's a religious family
and I when I was a child I would find
myself still includes my brother's
clothes so that I could put them on
because I thought but that's what I
wanted
when I left high school that is when
I got to know about that trans community
and I realized that I was a trans person
but my family has never accepted me I
only have one sister of mine uh young
sets of man who accepted me the way I am
and she has always tried to tell them
that
I'm their blood and they can't throw me
out but of course it's the culture in
Uganda they don't want to accept that
now there are many in Ugandan Society
who want to see this law passed can you
talk to us about
what is it in Ugandan Society in Ugandan
culture in the way that people live that
means they're so fearful of the LGBT
plus Community many African countries
believe in culture I believe in religion
so they always focus on especially when
we come to the religious aspect
they think of the Bible
so they feel like
they have to act according to what the
Bible tells them
no matter what
so it has been mostly influenced by
cultural and religious leaders and the
community at large when this bill was
stable in Parliament
we got religious leaders and cultural
leaders who visited the speaker of
Parliament and they also went to
Parliament to make sure they push for
this law to pass these evangelists that
come from Europe the U.S and the lover
they come and they always make sure they
have they support so it has been
influenced and there is a lot of
pressure and support that has come in
from outside they always want us to
fulfill the obligations of the Bible and
the culture a girl has to get married
and give birth to children and stay with
the husband in the house if a man has to
be with a woman and give birth and so on
we have been accused that a lot as the
gay community because I can give an
example a recent example of kovid when
kovid came into Uganda people in Uganda
started saying it's because there is an
increase in the gay community and God is
very mad at us that is why he has set
coverage to the country that leads to
violations of the LGBT persons
this house will not shy to restrict any
right to ex to the extent of the house
recognizing that recognizes protects and
safeguards the sovereignty of this
country
the morals of this country
the cultures
I know always legislate for our people
now those behind the law say it's
designed to strengthen traditional
Family Values they see homosexuality as
a threat and one that needs to be
eradicated
Schultz says the deputy director of the
Africa division at Human Rights Watch
just the mere fact that you identify as
an LGBT person you are not criminalized
but the criminalization comes when you
engage in sexual acts
but this particular act that was adopted
on Monday creates new offenses
such as promotion of homosexuality with
imprisonment for a term not exceeding 20
years and this puts ngos and activists
that are working in this area at risks
it also horribly includes death penalty
for acts considered as aggravated
homosexuality which is also a new
offense being created and acts that are
considered as aggravated homosexuality
under the law include having sexual acts
with children older persons persons with
mental illness persons with disabilities
the inclusion of persons with
disabilities is also discriminatory
because it doesn't consider persons with
disabilities having the agency to
consent to having sex the death penalty
could also be mattered if you give
someone a terminal illness after a
sexual act is there something unique
about
Uganda in making these kind of laws more
severe or do we need to look more widely
at the continent of Africa
Uganda is one country that has been
persistent about this particular law
wanted to create these new offenses and
reiterate that having sex same-sex Act
is a criminal offense
um in Uganda
also the law at the moment has a lot of
support in Uganda and this is because
there has been anti-lgbt Campaign
proponents which have been running
campaigns for months coming to the
region it would not be fair to lump all
African countries in the same basket and
unfortunately
when it comes to LGBT people in
sub-Saharan Africa regressive
developments have garnered considerable
International attention and that has
overshadowed the progress that has been
made recently this year you have other
countries in the region such as Angola
Botswana Gabon DeSoto Mozambique and
Seychelles in South Africa of course who
have decriminalized same-sex but on the
downside you have countries like
iswatini Burundi Ghana
Tanzania who are on the same wavelength
as Uganda and they actually do want to
adopt stricter laws and do not want to
recognize the rights of lgbti community
what part does organized religion
Christianity and Islam play in these um
these regressive laws
if you look at the econcontinent before
colonization there was no logo that was
um that was formerly criminalizing
homosexuality the trend of laws
criminalizing came from British colonial
laws or French Colonial laws where their
penal codes would have the offense of
sodomy and would criminalize the offense
of sodomy and colonization also brought
about the christianization of the
African continent but I think it's very
important to delineate religion when it
comes to rights Uganda is not a
religious State it's a secular State how
difficult does this new law make it for
people
the need to seek treatment for sexually
transmitted diseases
there has actually been
the global fund unaids and pep
which states that the anti-homosexuality
ACT will definitely obstruct health
education and the Outreach that can help
AIDS as a public threat
the reason also is that LGBT people in
Uganda will be discouraged from seeking
vital Health Services for fear of attack
punishment and further marginalization
because they will have to go and talk
about their sexual life and talk about
how they contracted HIV in some
instances to be able to access these
Healthcare Services
so this particular law might act as a
hindrance for hiv-positive person or for
anyone who has had sex or has had same
sex who's scared that they might have
contracted HIV to have access
to the health care services
a number of Western Nations the U.S and
the UK have criticized this law what
effects do you think that will have the
U.S the EU the UK have condemned it the
U.S has even said that it will provide
support to the LGBT community in Uganda
and that it has threatened to withdraw
visas uh for the speaker of the
parliament the danger
of
these nations threatening the government
for sanctions is that it can further
entrench rights especially if it comes
to withdrawal of funding no country has
done that yet neither the EU but if that
comes it could be dangerous for all
ugandans because Uganda relies a lot on
donor funding for its budget
so these countries and institutions need
to be careful when dealing when reacting
to this particular law to make sure that
the reaction does not cut back on
funding that could help the country or
the population
um further
so the U.N at the time this particular
bill was still being debated
categorized it as probability among the
worst of its kind in the world and
unfortunately we have not had any
reaction from the African Union
unit
[Music]
despite the increased risk to his life
Jay malucha sees hope for a future
Uganda where LGBT plus people live
freely and without fear yes I have I
have all sort of tuition for the nation
but one day one time uh which I'll
overcome I always think about these
different countries that have started
like us then they never started on talk
and they weren't accepted just from out
of the blue it was a struggle
a lot of advocacy a lot of
sensitizations that they did and they
were accepted I look at the U.S I look
at uh South Africa I look at all these
good countries that have these laws that
River the LGBT community yes of course
they are not 100 perfect but they are
better than us we can now even go to
court and petition or challenge the law
which wouldn't have been there if we
weren't brave enough and stand on our
two legs so I have hope that one day one
time we shall overcome and have tried
our best to see that we change a lot of
people there are many people who have
been changed through the advocacy
sensitization that we have done the good
work that we are doing the image that we
are showing the public that no matter
what they think we are this but no we
are peace this is who we are so I have a
feeling one day one time everything will
be good
my thanks to Jay malucha and ashwani
buddhu Schultz you've been listening to
the Sky News Daily with me Kamali
Melbourne
this episode was produced by Sola
aparicio and Amy Lakin the editor was
Philly Beaumont